[Music]
a woman who has actually just been
jailed after taking 150 driving tests
for other people that's oh
that's a good record
she's a hero that's what she is yeah i
think either at monterey park or
glendale yep no you're glad i heard that
the glendale dmp got shut down because
it's so corrupt they just hold the
envelope yeah they couldn't even clean
it up they just said we're
that's like bell remember bell uh the
other city government was all [ __ ] up
wild that really happened yeah well they
didn't shut the whole thing down but it
was so corrupt
everything everybody like that was like
working in the government and they're
all like family members and [ __ ] yeah
that already sounds correct you said
that the mayor's salary is one million a
year that's right we talked about that's
the one we were talking about yeah yeah
yeah but it's just making more than our
president that's hella funny that it's
just a whole family in there and it's
like nobody saw the signs until like the
third cousin was [ __ ] hired or what
right who's gonna tell on their family
members never hunter biden wouldn't he
wouldn't not my president i feel like
that was a joke and you should take that
[ __ ] back i did take it back okay i
do take it back and i apologize for me
i'll take it for you in the butt all
right so this lady is actually her name
is indirjeet cower k-a-u-r i believe
she's indian
um this was actually in south wales she
took tests between 2018 and 2020
uh and she literally has just been
jailed because 150 practical and theory
driving tests uh so aka like the written
and the [ __ ] actual driving south
wales is like a pretty small town area
right yeah so she's going to the same
[ __ ] tv oh they're like you again so
she's going yes
so in that area she's going to like
swansea carmarthen birmingham and london
in that entire area and like all the
similar to like the the dmvs i think
they call it the dvsa driver vehicle
standard agency or whatever dude how'd
you get away with that like there has to
be sunglasses different sunglasses
all kinds of different ones she's just
dying her hair like jason bourne and
[ __ ] like that for every [ __ ] test
[ __ ] it's jason bourne holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
so yeah jesus we just we just picked him
up in india
you might as well kill yourself because
he god you're done dude um eventually
those staff at test centers grew
suspicious and following a referral from
the dvsa an investigation was launched
uh and
the regional organized crime team for
southern whales had to come in in order
to investigate this 29 year old
29 years she was 29 years old she's
offering services to test applicants who
had difficulty speaking english
she's she's robin hood bro almost almost
there's a bunch of uh traffic schools
like that in monterey park when i um
what yeah when i used to get tickets
like i'm like oh i forgot to spend
saturday like eight hours my dad don't
waste your time and he was like all up
in the chinese newspaper so you would
just pay like extra like 200 bucks with
300 bucks and then they just signed it
off for you what kind of dad what kind
of father would do that what kind of
foster sick ass one yeah a practical one
there's a lot of them did you learn your
lesson no you didn't your dad's helping
you cut corn i learned that you can get
anything you want
with two hundred dollars that's a good
lesson but so like pay your way in the
service in that type of service it's
like uh
like what are they offering you for that
extra 200 bucks like like let's say you
guys so you don't have to go there so if
you got a ticket like have you been a
traffic school i have you just sit there
eight hours watching a stupid video so
somebody signed in who just looks asian
is like i'm bar kwon i don't think they
even sign in they just write off said oh
yeah barquan
oh cause they're running the traffic
school so you guys you guys are getting
caught absolutely can't you pay this
money they give you no education you get
nothing of value and then you leave with
nothing and no growth
you got conned
i do the online one you know what i mean
the online driving school when you get a
ch so like yeah i don't know if they had
that in the 56k days i think you're all
getting caught because i sold my car for
crypto and i don't even have a car
[Laughter]
joke's on you i don't drive yeah do you
think i
worry about getting points on my license
no i don't use my license
i have to buy drinks
which i can't
it's like if you get if you get a ticket
and you're not on probation already like
a speeding a traffic violation that
would be a point on your record that
like ups your insurance right you can
take online traffic school but the thing
is same thing nobody's [ __ ]
moderating you or anything like that so
you just click next and go through
everything and then once you get to the
test you can google every answer
and the test that test format or or even
if they mix up the variation of the
questions or like multiple choice or
whatever those answers are like
literally google and they sometimes put
like time limits on it so that you can't
scroll too fast you might have to wait
30 minutes before the next test to
pretend like you're actually reading but
other than that like
that's the best way to do traffic school
stuff see i was always like all these
[ __ ] cons right they're gonna
[ __ ] i paid 300 bucks they're gonna sign
me off all this [ __ ] i was like you know
what i'm gonna con you you're not gonna
extract any money i'm just gonna study
it for free [ __ ] and i go and i pass it
yeah yeah you still gotta pay the ticket
fine though [ __ ] no dude you know what
happened um i announced
i researched and i figured out how to do
that [ __ ] for free how to do what dude
joe goes to dmv and he starts cleaning
up trash he gets a job there and then
they just pay it off with him working
there that's what it sounds like like
washing dishes
i figured out a way yeah get it for free
he's like you put on this orange vest
start picking up all the trash
freeway on the freeway
yeah i ran a red light right and they
[ __ ] flashed
[ __ ] took a photography of me right
going [ __ ] right and i was like you
son of a [ __ ] you can avoid those the
the camera ones you just throw it away
that's what i do no no
i i heard that's like an actual thing
like if they catch you on a camera
camera once you chuck them it's like a
separate agency
i researched online and then what they
said is that those [ __ ] are
unconstitutional
right they gotta be there to get your
[ __ ] ticket i went up i went to the
court i was ready i had my [ __ ]
argument ready and when you showed up
they go
all right we're gonna read off this list
if you're on this list you're free to go
and then my name was on it and i said oh
[ __ ] i didn't even get to i want to
fight but they're like nah it's time to
go and i just left and then i have to
pay [ __ ] so you got cond of your time i
did
do you
think but there's a lesson here right
there's a lesson here right this is the
[ __ ] up part right what i found out is
they just it's a numbers game if you
don't [ __ ] show up then you're on the
hook
if you do show up they know that you
didn't [ __ ] up so when i what i was
doing was i made a right turn on the red
which is legal to do that's why i wanted
to [ __ ] fight it because i wasn't
actually running a red but they flashed
me and they sent me a [ __ ] bill so if
you're if you didn't do anything wrong
if you show up you're off the hook but
if you do show if you don't show up they
make you pay and that's the [ __ ] up
part
everything's a raccoon they're called
snitch tanks oh yeah yeah that's a
record but so they they see so you get
flash right did you see the flash i saw
the flash and i was like but that was
legal and i was like bitter about that
and then that printout goes to the city
government they see it and like holy
[ __ ] it's jason bourne
this guy crutches push dude
oh my god doing it he's doing 15 and a
20.
like at that point probably a shitbox
just like this feels like jesus christ
can't afford it looking like an asian
charlo
we got jason bourne in alhambra god damn
it
blows his brains out
so uh this lady would charge anywhere
from like 800 and 900 dollars worth uh
in order to take the theory tests and
practical exams and uh
based off of doing 150 of them at that
price and getting caught how much of a
jail time would you guys give her
[ __ ] free to go dude that's what i
would do
so she made like 800 grand over the
course of like maybe 80 g's huh oh 80g
that's [ __ ] sick dude she could pass
a test about jail i would let her go i
thought she had like thousands of people
i think he said hundreds uh about 126
000 minimum hundreds of people huh yeah
150 people so at least 126. she's not
businesswoman that's legit yeah so does
she get more of the time based off of
the money she's scammed or more about
the principal where she's frauding the
government i yeah i don't know if it's
about the money and probably the
principle though right because that's
not like that's not like that much money
compared to i mean i'm sure she's
probably fined for it or anything but
she's like screwing the system do you
think she's doing something unethical
here because i feel like she's providing
a service for people who can't speak
english okay
just laughs at his own [ __ ] point
oh man
drive your head very far back the amount
of times i
[ __ ] died from someone who like
did cannot read a [ __ ] sign that's
true refuses to like learn how to drive
it's
like it's a lot it's a lot
yeah it's every time you get in the car
and you're in monterey park
your insurance is higher here if you
live here yeah because everyone's trying
to drive to kill you i just like the
idea that she she's this is the uk right
yeah she is screwing
this system this good system where the
[ __ ] prime minister is like ape and a
bunch of public funds and
we gotta get me dragged
i guess not i guess he doesn't have to
no because he paid her to get his
license
it's a [ __ ] what did she get like
five years maybe
five ten i don't think she should get
any jail time no no i think she should
pick up trash outside the dmv that's it
she was sentenced to eight months in
prison four of which she'll spend behind
bars oh that's nothing just come out and
do it again yeah dude
no four years out no no eight months in
prison four of those months she'll spend
years eight months no [ __ ] that's like a
[ __ ] murderer yeah yeah
that's it for murder
oh [ __ ] whereas brittany griner had
pleaded guilty and now she's looking up
to 10 years in russia that's
that's the gulag though that's the gulag
they wanna they want a bargaining chip
but she had weed juice or something okay
bad news it's like cbd all that's bad
news man what they're gonna do i heard
what they're gonna do is they're like
hey here's a basketball you'll be free
to go if you could dunk the ball and she
couldn't dude that's the biggest problem
with wnba that's going to be the biggest
problem
they got to lower
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you